bioplastik teuer also super elastische
reifen so heißt die neue unvorstellbare
erfindung der nasa eigentlich ging es
nur um einen neuen reifen für einen
zukünftigen mars-rover der ergebnis ist
aber tatsächlich eine super alternative
zum luftreifen für autos lkw flugzeuge
und so weiter für uns alle
die massenhaft vorteile mit sich bringt
welche genau und in welchen bereichen
das neue rad auch hier auf der erde
schon bald eingesetzt werden können sie
jetzt in klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
ein forschungsteam von glenn research
center das der nasa angehört hat jetzt
tatsächlich eine redewendung wahr werden
lassen ihre erfindung ein rad aus einem
drahtgeflecht das im ersten moment
vielleicht an die ketten rüstung aus dem
mittelalter erinnert und das hält
extreme belastung aus also genau richtig
für den einsatz im weltraum
denn das thema dort ist schwierig und
das wissen auch die ingenieure und
ingenieurinnen die die entsprechenden
fahrzeuge immer weiter optimieren wollen
doch dieser schritt ist wirklich
sagenhaft denn der super lästig da ist
zum einen fast unvorstellbar
pannensicher verantwortlich dafür ist
die neuartige verwendung von sogenannten
form gedächtnis legierungen vielleicht
hat er das mal in eurem chemieunterricht
mitbekommen form gedächtnis regierungen
können unter gewissen umständen nach
einer verformung wieder ihre
ursprüngliche gestalt annehmen und das
birgt enormes potenzial das
beispielsweise schon seit längerer zeit
in der medizintechnik genutzt wird
werden durch stance also kleine röhrchen
stabilisiert diese und weitere vorteile
hat sich jetzt auch die nase zugemacht
der super lässig teil besteht im detail
aus einem nachgiebigen reifen der nicht
genetisch ist also nicht luft gefüllt
nicht aufgepumpt wird tragenden
komponente stellt ein geflecht aus einer
nickel titan legierung dadurch wird er
tatsächlich super elastisch er kann
damit eine dehnung von bis zu 10
unbeschadet überstehen
zum vergleich elastische materialien wie
feder stelle halten den um in der
größenordnung von maximal 0,5 prozent
aus bevor sie nach gehen dadurch bedingt
wären bei off road bedingungen
tatsächlich auch erhöhte
fahrgeschwindigkeiten weil es für diese
reifen ja quasi keinen widerstand gibt
möglich und sie können sich an fast
alles anpassen das heißt ein feldweg
wird quasi zur autobahn
zitat diese technologie kommt selbst mit
hohen belastungen und übermäßigen
verformen klar das schreibt die nasa auf
ihrer webseite
und es gibt noch weitere vorteile die
tragfähigkeit der reifen wird erhöht und
es wird kein innerer rahmen gebraucht
das heißt die reifen beziehungsweise rat
anordnung ist also in ihrem aufbau sehr
vereinfacht zudem sei auch die traktion
also die kraftübertragung des reifen auf
die straße den här
könig luftreifen gleichzusetzen oder
sogar überlegen
die nasa bewerb den super lässig teuer
mit den folgenden begriffen sicher stark
robust einfach vielseitig und leicht und
ihr könnt es euch denken anwendungen für
diese erfindung gibt es massenhaft
gelände militär bau fahrzeuge könnten
davon profitieren
die nasa denkt aber auch schon eine
einsatz bei flugzeugen und eben
herkömmlichen autos nach und wenn ihr
kein video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollen die ich
in zukunft darüber machen werde dann
drückt mehr hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergessen nicht den genau auf die
knochen nur dann verpasst er kein video
hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken mit tempo 200 unterirdisch
durch die stadt sehr spannendes video
ansonsten bis dann flattern